prendidas las alarmas tras el sismo de
magnitud 6.2 que sorprendió en la
madrugada de este miércoles a guatemala
al sur de méxico y al norte de el
salvador las autoridades trabajan en
identificar y cuantificar los daños
materiales y los daños a personas que
haya dejado el intenso movimiento
telúrico en guatemala por ejemplo se
reportan cerca de 25 mil personas
afectadas en 7 diferentes departamentos
se destacan entre ellos quetzaltenango y
guatemala el que cobija a la capital del
país sin embargo las autoridades
explican que este tipo de afectaciones
corresponden a derrumbes en 12
carreteras nacionales a años al interior
de las viviendas y también a colapsos
estructurales pero hacen un llamado
especial sobre todo a que los
guatemaltecos la población en general
mantenga la calma en este tipo de
eventos sísmicos que son tan frecuentes
en guatemala sobre todo para evitar
afectaciones indirectas como paros
respiratorios y paros cardíacos que en
determinados casos pueden llegar a poner
en peligro la vida de las personas